I'm getting ready for a lot of things.
A lot of things.
It's spring so we're starting to get the gardens ready,...
...and my tomatoes are legendary here in my own neighborhood.
My daughter is about to start kindergarten next year,...
...and so we're moving just so she can belong to a better school.
I'm getting ready to do something, too.
I'm running for president.
Americans have fought their way back from tough economic times,...
...but the deck is still stacked in favor of those at the top.
Every day Americans need a champion and I wanna be that champion.
So you can do more than just get by; you can get ahead...
...and stay ahead.
Because when families are strong, America is strong.
So I'm hitting the road to earn your vote.
Because it's your time,...
...and I hope you'll join me on this journey.